donc vous avez respirer trois fois
profondément
très bien et maintenant vous allez
laisser venir des images et les
sensations vous allez vous voir
simplement ce matin en vous levant comme
une caméra qui vous regardent ça vous
vous connaissez
et dès que vous voyez ce matin vous me
dit ça y est très bien
maintenant vous allez vous voir à l'âge
de 10 ans et vous laisser venir les
images les sensations si vous êtes
dedans à l'extérieur d'une maison ou à
l'intérieur
vous pouvez me parler me dire si vous
êtes dedans ou à l'extérieur moi je suis
dans un chalet en savoie d'accord vous
aviez quel âge il a maintenant dix ans
comment vous sentez la seringue anxieux
ou sera donc je suis anxieux qu'est ce
que vous ressentez de cette anxiété
pourquoi parce que je suis pas voilà je
suis pas bien je peux comptant ou par an
sont pas là ou dans mes parents sont là
mais ma grand mère qui habite avec une
qui me fatigue d'un accord très bien
maintenant vous allez vous voir l'âge de
5 ans pareil vous laisser venir voilà
vous êtes au
moment la bid en algérie oui
j'ai tout
dans un village à côté de doran d'accord
et vous êtes à l'intérieur de la maison
à l'extérieur juin d'un accord dans un
champ dans la cuisine dans quel endroit
dans le salon dans le salon très bien
maintenant vous allez revenir beaucoup
plus loin en arrière dans une de vos
vies passées avant la vie actuelle sur
terre en tant qu'être humain et vous
laisser venir les images des sensations
voilà le lieu l'endroit que vous
ressentez la
wii
je vois le moyen-âge d'accord vous êtes
tous
dans une
armée qui attaque un château d'accord
vous êtes guerriers en croisade l'on
sorte de croisade on attaque un château
d'accord vous êtes commandant ou dans la
norme dans l'armée guerrier vous vous
sentez avec l'armure avec les armes des
armes épée dames d'accord des armes vous
avez quel âge à peu près là sept
personnes à peu près qu'elle h 17 18 ans
vous étiez jeune et comment vous
ressentez cette bataille vous avez vous
appréhendé où je sais que je vais mourir
ce sont santé cette mort arriver oui
et comment vous voyez mourir là avec
nous boulet contre mu un boulet qui vous
arrive sur le corps directement en
pleine poitrine
et au moment où vous voyez à langer
morts qu'est ce que vous ressentez j'ai
pris le boulet je
ressentais autres énergies
quand elle sort de ce corps à quoi
pensez-vous
que je vais survivre en fait c'est à
dire vous êtes amant ça veut dire que
vous êtes conscient qu'on peut votre
corps est là n'est que votre esprit là
c'est à dire que vous allez survivre
c'est à dire que vous êtes déjà vous
êtes vivant vous avez cette conscience
là mais vous voyez ce corps là allongé
très bien vous allez remonter dans une
autre vie encore plus lointaine à
l'époque que vous avez vécu toujours sur
terre en tant qu'être humain voilà
l'endroit que vous ressentez là vous
êtes tous là l'eau un bateau romain un
bateau romain oui vous faites quoi c'est
gérard bourrât mai
un galérien c'est comme si vous étiez un
peu esclave vous aviez quel âge là à peu
près je suis plus âgées il est dur en
cinq ans c'est dur
très dur
et plus tard cette personne que
fait-elle elle a vécu toujours sur ce
bateau ou par la suite elle a pu partir
de ce bateau
là pu partir comment en se jetant à la
mer en s'échappant
maintenant on va aller voir encore une
vie encore plus lointaine
voilà endroit le lieu où vous êtes
une grande vie commencée depuis ancien
l'époque quelle est cette ville
baby gone baby lieu unique que faites
vous là je suis marche en marchant ou
vendée coin nous serons du savon
comme si vous étiez artisans oui quel
âge at il cette personne car 40 ans
regardez là cette personne quand elle
avait dix ans que fait-elle là ce jeune
homme que fait-il zhu zhu yu dans la rue
dans la rue à 20 ans que fait-il
seul le samu
vous allez ouvrir les yeux mais on va
essayer de voir avant votre guide
est ce que c'est un homme une femme
laisser venir ce qui vous vient à
l'esprit
rome 8 heures un homme
vous pourriez me dire ils vous dis là
dans votre esprit
c'est la même vie est à dire chaque fois
que vous reproduisez comme une sorte de
galère ouais et peu après vers la fin de
votre vie à une sagesse qui s'instaure
voix
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit encore
laisser venir
il entend notre message pour vous
continuez continuez votre chemin votre
destin qu'est-ce qu'il peut vous dire
encore
très bien
saleh respirez trois fois profondément
mais vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
c'est pas mal et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
y mettez un peu de bleu